نتحول الان
لنقل هذه الافاده الصحفيه كلمه لدانييل
هجار اطلاق النار تم اصابه وحده التحكم من
المهم ان اؤكد
للجمهور الاضرار ستصلح وبسبب الاستعداد
المقدم فان الوحده ستقوم بالعمل ونحن نحقق
في الحادث من اجل ان نعرف ونتعلم
وندعم الدفاع الجوي
لم يكن اصابات في هذه في هذاه الهجمات
هجمنا بالامس عدد من اهداف لحسب الله من
بينها وحده لاطلاق الصواريخ لحزب الله
وقضينا على سبعه مخربين عدد منهم قاموا
باطلاق النار باتجاه اراضينا قبل اطلاق
النار وبعد اطلاق النار وبعضهم لم يتمكن
من اطلاق النار اليوم واصلنا الهجمات طوال
اليوم هذه الهجمات تضر بقوى رضوان الاضرار
بقوى رضوان في حزب الله في جنوب لبنان
تاتي الى ابعادهم عن الحدود ونحن مصممون
بمواصله ان نعطي هناك منطقه امنيه وايضا
ان نعطي الامن للسكان اريد ان اقول
للجمهور هناك تحدي في الشمال ونحن مستعدون
لذلك ونحن منتشرون على طول الحدود
ومستعدون بشكل كبير في الدفاع والهجوم
رئيس الاركان قام اليوم
بالانتشار في يهودا والسام
هذه القوه تعمل وقامت باطلاق بالقيام 40
عمليه وفي خلال بالامس تم
مقتل احدى الجنود احد الجنود وايضا ضد
عمليات الارهاب في جني في الساعات الصباح
ق قتل احد قتل احد الاشخاص وتم ملاحقه
المخربين ونواصل ملاحقتهم حتى نصل اليهم
رئيس الاركان دعم عمل القوات ضد الارهاب
وضد في الدفاع وايضا في الشوارع والمناطق
والبلدات نواصل العمل ضد الارهاب في يهو
والسامره في قطاع غزه القوات تواصل
التركيز في تفكي قدرات حماس في المركز وفي
الجنوب اريد ان اتوجه الى عائلات
المخطوفين
انا اؤكد لكم ان جيش الدفاع يعمل وسيعمل
هنا الثير من ال معظمها سريه وكل هذه
العمليات بهدف واحد وهو ان نضغط الضغط
العسكري لاعاده المخطوفين
رد قوي لسلاح الجو وايضا مهاجمه بيروت ضمن
هذه الهجمات
مهاجمه وحده المراقبه والقياده
الجويه ايضا هناك الكثير من المنظومات
وهناك تحقيقات
ونحسن الدفاع في
المنطقه الهجمات في لبنان قويه جدا واحد
ما الاهداف التي واجهناها ونفك كها هي
الصواريخ
ارجو هذه
الوحدات لحزب الله وعلى مدى السنوات التي
بناها حزب الله من اجل ان
يضر باسرائيل نحن نواصل مهاجمات وايضا
هاجمنا العديد من القدرات
التي تقلل من قدراتنا الجويه والسلاح
الجوي يعمل بحريه في لبنان
وبتفوق كبير يهاجمون وكل التهديدات
الارهابيه ضد اسرائيل وهكذا سنواصل العمل
الكثير من العمليات لا اريد ان تطرق اليها
وانا
بهذه
ر اصابه هذا هذا هذه المنشاه رد جيش
الدفاع كان
بسيطا وهل هذا يعني ما هو تقدير لجيش
الدفاع ما هي
موقف جيش الدفاع بالنسبه اعاده المواطنين
الى شمالي قطاع غزه انا افهم اصابه
المنشاه هو ضم
الرد وهذه
الاضرار وايضا في الموازنه بالامس حزب
الله تم مقتل سبعه مخربين في هذا اليوم
سبعه مخربين سبعه من رجاله الذين هناك
جنازات وفي جنوب لبنان لا يوجد اصابات
لدوله
اسرائيل المنشاه
تعمل اخذنا من حزب الله قدرات التي بناها
خلال سنوات وايضا من اجل للاضرار بتفوق
الجوي السلاح الجوي يتحرك في جنوب لبنان
وفي لبنان بحريه كبيره هذه هي الصوره ويجب
ان نعرضها على الجمهور هناك لنا تحدي اخر
وهو ان نبعد رضوان عن الحدود وان نعطي
مكانيه امنيه
مختلفه عندنا تحدي وهو ان نعطي وضعا امنيا
مختلفا وايضا في الجنوب بشكل
ممنهج
فيما يتعلق بعوده السكان الى شمال قطاع
غزه في القطع ما زال قطاع غزه مفصولا هناك
ممر امني هناك مواطنون مازالوا في الشمال
وهناك عدد من المواطنين في الشمال وايضا
هناك الحركه لا حركه بين الشمال والجنوب
سوى الحركه الامنيه
والانسانيه راينا في الاسبوع الماضي نصر
الله خارج
الملجا
وايضا تحدثهم عن محمد ضيف بدون اطراف
وايضا ان نصر الله يختبئ في
الملجا وايضا فيما يتعلق بلون
المراقبه الذي هل كان بسبب الاضرار
بالقاعده لن اطرق لا علاقه بين الاور
واعيد م
وحده المراق الجو مع منومات اخرى تعمل
وايضا هناك من المنظومات
تعمل وهذا غير مرتبط واحد بالاخر نحن
نشرنا
بالامس القدرات نحو 70 الف ملف وايضا
بعضها كانت في المراقبه تحت الارض و تماما
من اجل
ان هذه تحت الارض كانوا
ذه
المتها واض هناك امور مهمه جدا حسب
الاهداف
والحماس ليس فقط في
غزه شكرا لكم ومساء
الخير اذا كان هذا دانييل هجري المتحدث
باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي في احاطته اليوميه
ومعنا الان من تل ابيب مراسله الجزيره
نجوان سمري نجوان انطلاقا مما قاله ها
جاري بخصوص مجريات الحرب في غزه وملف
الاسرى وملفات اخرى كيف يمكن قراءته وربطه
بمجمل الخلافات بين القيادات
الاسرائيليه يعني من الواضح ان هذا البيان
لجاري ركز بالمجمل اكثر على قضيه اصابه
القاعده الجويه في جبل الجرمق في الشمال ي
والاصابه كانت يوم امس جراء استهدافها
بعشرات الصواريخ من من الصواريخ التي
اطلقتها اطلقها حزب الله يوم امس على هذه
المنطقه يوم امس كان هناك تكتم و منع
النشر عن الاضرار التي تسببت لهذه القاعده
الجويه ولمنظمات
والمراقبه للمنطقه هذه واحده من اهم
القواعد العسكريه بالنسبه لاسرائيل في تلك
المنطقه لكن لكن هذا اليوم وقبل هذا
الاعلان من ه جاري كان قد اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي بانه بالفعل تم الحاق الضرر
دون ان يتم تحديد ماهيه هذا الضرر في هذه
القاعده الجويه والان غاري ايضا سمعنا بان
احدى الصحفيات سالته عن هذا الضرر الا انه
قال ضرر بشكل عام دون ان يحدد هذا الضرر
وماهيه هذا الضرر وقال ان القاعده الجويه
تواصل بالعمل ومنظومه المراقب المراقب
تواصل العمل بشكل او باخر بخصوص سير
العمليات في غزه عاد واكد بطبيعه الحال
على ربما تكرار لتصريحاته كل يوم بان
العمليه مستمره وبان هناك تقدم لقوات
الجيش وتحدث عما يحرزه الجيش من انجازات
كما يصفها هاري علما ان هذا اليوم نشرت
ايضا صحيفه دعوت احرونوت بهذا الخصوص بان
غالبيه الانجا التي يتحدث عنها الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي لا سما وانه يوم امس
في بيانه المسائي رصد تلخيصا لثلاثه اشهر
من الحرب هي انجازات تكتيكيه ليست اكثر
ولكنها بعيده كل البعد عن تحقيق الانجازات
الاستراتيجيه التي حددت لهذه الحرب بخصوص
ال الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه راينا بانه
ايضا يقول بان الجيش يعمل كل ما بوسعه من
اجل الافراج عنهم واستعادتهم وهذا ياتي
ايضا بعد تصريحات ادلى بها قبل قليل وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يواف جلنت خلال لقاء له
مع عائلات الاسرى الجنود تحديدا المحتجزين
في غزه واخبرهم ب وفقا لما نقلته وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه بان هذه الحرب لن تتوقف
قبل ان تستعيد اسرائيل كل اسراه المحتجزين
في غزه مشددا على موقفه السابق والذي
يكرره ايضا طله الوقت تحديدا يؤاف جلنت
بانه كما يعتقد ان الضغط العسكري او مزيد
من الضغط العسكري على حركه حماس سيساهم في
اجبارها على التوصل الى صفقه تبادل
والتنازل في هذا السياق لكن بطبيعه الحال
نعم وسيله اشكرك جزيل الشكر نجوان سمري
حتى الان مراسلتنا من تلبيب